glory lightfoot beetlejuice  [Music]  it ain't pretty i can't sugarcoat this  there's nothing we can do we don't have  enough grease for the lens there's  nothing we could do with photoshop  this is the mayor of chicago to my  friends in the lgbtq  plus community the supreme court is  coming for us next this moment has to be  a call to arms  this call to arms call to arms how can  we analyze a call to arms in any other  way than what she literally is saying a  call to arms get your weapons and do  something that is far more of a call for  an insurrection than anything that  donald trump did on january 6 when he  was saying let's peacefully protest to  peacefully and  patriotically make your voices heard the  woman is calling for an insurrection and  she will get away with it